[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time I'm Rhett and I'm
linked this week at the round table of
dim lighting
we're shopping for some new jobs
shopping for some new jobs I don't
necessarily know you got a little uh
is that a deodorant stain
on your black shirt I noticed that you
know even though we've been we we've you
know deodorant we've seen we've seen
each other uh for approximately 30
minutes already today I just haven't
I haven't looked at my shoulder
well I just got it I don't know what
that was
you you uh you'd like practicing for the
for like a track and field event there's
a little chalk doing some doing some uh
a little pommel horse rock climbing
you're a problem horse guy yeah yeah
that's it uh how much does Palmer horse
pay
probably not much at all in fact
um
I mean Palm a horse doesn't pick it's
well known it's well known that Olympic
athletes unless they are the cream of
the crop and also have like some other
stuff happen almost everyone else is
like in debt not making a lot of money
like you've seen that documentary about
gold medalists
I haven't read uh I don't think I've
seen it either but I I know about it and
I feel like I know the vibe you know
what I'm saying last thing I want to
know about that documentary depressed
about former Olympians if you're not
like Phelps or uh Simone you know what
I'm saying like you you don't
it's a difficult life after that you
work so hard on that pommel horse and
then fine I'm giving up the pommel yes
yeah I'm just what I'm trying to get to
is that you need to back off the pommel
horse before you start riding that
pommel horse you know what I'm saying is
there you don't ride the pommel horse
into the sunset
no it's pretty stationary yeah you just
sit there your whole life
you can watch a good song I don't want
to know where it is I don't want to just
discourage gymnasts and also I think
it's a thing to get your kids in a lot
of kids get into gym gymnast stuff right
right keep them off the streets
gymnastics is really the term that we
use not gymnast stuff
gymnastics a lot of kids get into
gymnastics learning how to do a
somersault learn how to do a backflip
that stuff you'll take with you pay off
pay off later in life but you're not
gonna make any money doing it right if
you need to get out of something quick
that like has a low hanging ceiling
maybe you're in a cave you need to do a
reverse
somersault right and flexibility is
important right let's say there's a bear
deep in that cave you got to do some
backwards rolls out of that thing you
might have to flip right over him if
he's standing at the guard at the edge
right in the mouth of the cave and you
want to get past him do one of those
Contra jumps yeah those guys could ball
up like I don't know what do you know
what it was because their parents put
them in gymnasium yep yep yep
if you don't
if you're not following while we're
talking about this yes we are going to
be talking about other jobs that we
might uh get one day other jobs that you
can get I think I don't know if I'm
gonna get another job at this point but
odd jobs because we do
what might be described as an odd job
yeah we do and that got me thinking that
uh just yesterday as a matter of fact
both of us had to individually fill out
this registration form for this industry
thing that we're registering for uh-huh
and we didn't talk about it we did not
talk about it we did not cross consult
there was no cross-reference
and there was a section where you had to
choose your industry and then there was
a section where you had to choose your
particular role in that industry and
there was many options in both first of
all there was a write-in part and what
you're talking about is like the pull
down pull down good gosh I've never seen
a longer pull-down menu
you know it was like a joke click on the
thing
so many so many Industries so many
professions but in the write-in section
before that it's like tell us tell us a
little bit about yourself
I'd not only said some things about me
but you know I had to throw some things
in about you just for context yeah but
then I said that did you use my full
name you were also no you were also
registering I used your full name if you
weren't allowed in
then that was fine with me as long as I
was that's what I said okay well I did
not say that
but I guess I could go back and edit it
I threw you under the bus I did say I
make a mean paella that was one of the
things I said in that section
that is so
not
uh what's the word
um when when something needs appropriate
when something is not uh relevant
it said tell us about yourself
what you're into
what's the word what's the word I'm
thinking about cooking is a big part of
my life I know it is what's the word I'm
thinking about it's not it's a two it's
like this is not a is
that's not two syllables no that's
actually Four
way too many syllables it'll come to me
tweet it at me hashtag year biscuits um
okay well
the thing that uh really struck me
though was the pull down menu getting to
this question which I you know people
end up asking you what you do for a
living and we've talked before about how
there's not a straight answer for this
question
uh for us and it kind of depends on the
audience it depends on who's asking the
question and what kind of conversation I
want to ensue
do you want me to say what I put for the
thing because I kind of went right on
the nose with it I didn't think too hard
yep
uh for Indus it was an industry
something like I put digital I put
digital I did not
okay but I'm almost get pulled down
before you go before let's let's talk
there first okay
so
I didn't see digital the first time I
didn't look for it there's probably a
hundred
and I saw television media and so I was
like okay yeah we you know yeah I mean
yes we make television we talk about
what we do as Television right because
let me think if you think about it well
it is I mean it's like you watch it on
your TV it's visual it's televisual
uh we have shows Etc and so I before I
saw Digital television show we don't
make any television well we have we have
we have made several TV shows okay okay
yeah we have okay
um and
so in the context of this registration I
was like I think this is more
appropriate anyway
and so when I saw digital I was like I'm
not changing it I'm not changing it to
digital and yes
there's a little bit of like chip you
know chip on my shoulder-ishness about
digital
even though in practice I completely
embrace it as we've talked about before
especially this year complete Embrace of
the digital nature of what we do
but in the context of this application I
was like I'm not going to change it I
thought the first one would then send us
on different paths where like it would
just be a subset for what our occupation
was within that industry but everything
was available in the occupation pulled
down as well and it was even more stuff
oh yeah it was like hundreds I mean
there was like
um magician was one of them I did not
see that Illusionist was also one of
them apparently not the same thing well
yeah talk to Copperfield puppeteer
puppeteer
I'm a digital Puppeteer what if I was
that
hey some people are
good for them the first thing I looked
for in this pull down menu like Shane
was host
yeah host wasn't one of them host was
not an option uh news anchor was one
yeah I almost put that
I'm gonna tell you a visual news anchor
a lot of times I put like another man
not one if I fill out an insurance
application or something like that or
like if you're buying a car and you have
to like put occupation I put producer I
put yeah I'll put producer there
um because then it doesn't lead to
anything it's just like okay I got it
but I didn't put that on this one
I put
content creator I mean I just I didn't
see that one content creator I was like
okay yeah so basically you're a digital
content creator yeah I am dude yeah
yeah I don't want to be your friend
too late
um got him it's not as bad as digital
influencer though yeah uh influencer was
another one yeah I saw that one I was
like hell no and I'm just averse to that
I am not that first of all yeah yeah I'm
not I'm not anybody I I influence people
how did I say did I emphasize the wrong
influence influence
um people
um but I'm not an influencer that's
somebody whose job it is to just tell
you to buy things
I tell you to buy things as a way to
then do my job which is not telling you
to buy things we don't make life yes I
tell you to buy we don't make lifestyle
choices
or even content choices that are product
driven
that's what when I think of an
influencer that's what I think of
um and also I think a lot of people have
an image in their mind when they think
of an influencer in fact when I was at
that uh
fundraiser party thing I was telling you
about and
I got into a conversation with a guy I
was like he was like what do you do I
was like
I make YouTube videos for a living you
know I was like I'm just gonna I'm gonna
just cut to the chase
it's like oh you're an influencer I was
like well
uh I'm probably not what you have in
mind when you say influencer oh a little
prickly
I mean because I'm a 45 year old dad you
know what I'm saying like this
I don't know I'm just yeah
I didn't put influencer I didn't put
content creator what did you put founder
founder because that's what it says on
my little thing that we have in our
office yeah you got one too it says
mythical entertainment rep McLaughlin
founder everyone at mythical has a
little glass
little thing that's on their desk you're
a co-founder
co-founder one of them well here's the
thing founder in the end in the industry
what do you do for a living I'm a
Founder co-founder you did found
something but you're not a Founder
you're not going around finding stuff I
mean in the context of the first
question
television media founder no you're not
no I'm a lion I'm in the television
media business and the business that I
do television media through I am the the
founder of the only founder I am one of
the founders but co-founder was not an
option you're an overly self-aware I
wrote liar I wrote co-founder in the
description I said I said along with my
lifelong best friend
I well I said I founded along with I
mean this the co is implicit because if
you're a co-producer on something we
know because we were so people told us
about this co-producer does not mean you
produce a long it's like associate you
know what I'm saying like it's like oh
yeah yeah you're not the producer lesser
producer yeah all these terms you can't
say Co
s so anyway you're a digital content
creator and I'm a television media
founder which brings me to another thing
which brings me to another thing that I
have no control over
but people have pointed out on Twitter
the difference in the way we're
described in a Google search I've seen
this and uh I am described as an actor
and you are described as a YouTuber and
again this isn't something that any
influence over I I mean I might because
we're not I might be an influencer or
not but
um
yeah so how do you feel about that
because I didn't plan that either I just
don't care
you know what if you meet me I'm I'm
uncategorizable that's how I like to
think about it you know I don't like
labels
uh that's a label
not liking label is a label and a lot of
people who say that don't realize that
they're just labeling themselves what's
what's the label someone who doesn't
like a label
yeah but that's not a label that's a lot
it's too many words to be on that's like
saying ah like if you can't print it off
in one of those label makers to me it's
not a label oh no okay and I'm saying
this as someone who likes to say I don't
know you don't pin me down and and I
don't like to identify with an ideology
well that's my ideology let's just be
honest I mean my ideology is liking to
seem like I'm not ideologyless yeah is
an ideology I don't think you can't
listen you no matter where you go you're
still gonna be in a box
even if it's the box that's outside of
the box that you don't want to be in
it's labeled into another verse
yep was that on there what about
label-less uh because there was there
were several questions where the answer
was prefer not to say but this was not
one of them you couldn't say I prefer
not to say what I do for a living fun
fact
um uh J.R.R Tolkien almost called
Legolas labelus
laborless label-less that's a that is
either a really convenient fact or a
mediocre joke
it's mediocre
and then if I made a joke about being
ableist that would be an inappropriate
joke yep until you didn't do that I
didn't do that
um so anyway I'm not ableist
this um
this digital content creator and this
television media founder are going to
have a discussion today about other jobs
that they could have or you could have
and maybe you do have in fact legal is
better not be ableist let me tell you
right now
if you I do not ruin Lord of the Rings
for me if that's the case I don't want
to hear it um
if you have one of these jobs that we're
going to talk about today you have to
call in you have to call them it it is
it is mandatory this is live we don't
answer the phone 1888
if you know someone
who has one of these jobs it is
mandatory for you to contact them and
force them to call in and say that it is
their job
okay now coming from a television media
founder so you better listen oh man stop
the presses
okay I founded television media
I deserve respect okay
don't listen to this digital content
creator that's a dime a dozen you go to
high school with a bunch of digital
contact users you know what I'm saying
why are you going to high school again
don't don't be hanging around high
schools I'm just saying if you're in
high school like there's like four
people in your high school who are
digital content creators
nothing wrong with it I'm just saying
it's not how I describe myself
um
there's also a couple of rappers and uh
if you're in La yeah sure yeah it's
definitely some rappers uh and
apparently Lincoln is fancing himself
some sort of a rapper I don't know we
now have a family thread and
um that's been re-enlivened by some
pictures of the dogs that we just pass
around sometimes the cat and uh Lincoln
will reply in couplets he will rhyme for
rhyme things this is exciting I'll have
to look what's the name of your family
thread fam all caps fam that's pretty
cool do you have one yeah I mean I mean
Barbara and Sean's people
oh so it's doggy Centric too yeah that
is the name of our okay thread and of
course the four of us have a family
thread
the four of us meaning us and our wives
yep we have yeah we're not a family but
we have a family threat
and it is called
absolute unit
and I don't I don't remember what I
think we were hanging out one time and
Jesse had just discovered what the term
absolute unit meant and she like wanted
to share it with everyone including
people who had known about it for many
years okay well that was a
mischaracterization uh she my wife is
the most internet Savvy of the four of
us by far what do you what do you what's
all of a sudden you're getting you think
my wife didn't know what absolutely
that's how I remember it no it was
someone posted something in the in the
chat that was uh that was a big thing
and it was the meme was absolute unit it
was and I don't know who posted them so
was it Christy that didn't know what
absolutely you know was potentially but
I don't remember if it was someone who
didn't know but if it was somebody else
that's definitely not my one Jesse
didn't know that it was a sports term
that's what I was saying absolute unit
is something that comes from the World
of Sports
and it's been around for decades
it's not something that's and it's been
repurposed as a meme in the in a meme
which she understood what it meant I'm
not saying she didn't know what it meant
but she didn't know about what
percentage of people do you think know
the absolute unit was a sports term
before it was a meme I'd say hey seven
percent opposite I wasn't like hey I'm a
television media founder you got to
watch yourself around I wasn't I mean
what did what did you do what did you
think I was doing here like make sure
you seem like an idiot you said the
reason that we named it was because my
wife didn't know what it was and I was
like I think that's a
mischaracterization
okay
it's a good name for a thread though
well and I think she did name that
I will give her credit for that I think
it was a picture of a really muscular
dog
could have been a big duck
ear biscuits is supported by chime they
told adages that money can't buy
happiness but not worrying about where
your money comes from can definitely Aid
in that department that's where chime
can help you smile more they were just
named the number one most loved banking
app with payday up to two days early and
fee free overdrafts up to 200 they offer
Financial Peace of Mind in your wallet
all of this with no annual fees large
security deposits or credit checks to
apply see for yourself while chime is so
loved at chime.com ear that's chime.com
ear chime is a financial technology
company not a bank banking services and
debit card provided by The Bancorp Bank
or stride Bank in a members FDIC Early
Access to direct deposit funds depends
on payer spot me eligibility
requirements and overdress limit Supply
seetime.com spot me chime was a 2021
number one most downloaded banking app
in the US according to apptopia
I'm wearing the mythical wrandler mascot
sweatshirt it looks good that's Sports
boy he is an absolute unit there's two
of these there's this one that I'm
wearing the gray version and then there
is a red version with the same design
and a different different color scheme
so Collegiate uh it is Loosely based on
this is what the merch team told us it's
Loosely based on the way that Mr Wolf is
tough losing on um the I think it's to
Tuffy is just the head right well that's
I think that's his name dude why do they
call him Mr and Mrs woofer is it Tuffy
and well we should I should know this I
can't be talking about NC State mascot
names
I bet Jesse knows I'll put NC mascot
name and Ramses came up oh gosh that's
really
um it's both Mr and Mrs wolf and Tuffy
Tuffy wolf that's their last name I
guess
so get that at mythical.com this is an
ad
um oh Tuffy is the actual dog that shows
up
oh so Mr and Mrs wolf is the mascot
I know I'm not saying wolf right and
Tuffy is the dog
There's an actual wolf look at that
that's amazing I should meet him that's
cool a lot bigger than you think he's
probably just a husky
you know no they you can get
he's like part wolf some sort of a part
wolf
okay do you want to hear about some jobs
yeah how do you how are you gonna do
this you're just going to tell me about
him
yeah okay
all right do you want me do you want to
be quizzed on them
at the end what do you think the first
one I'm gonna say yes
psychic quiz
um this first one is one uh that I would
be very excited about and I believe that
your wife would be even more excited
about since we're talking about each
other's wives I'm only saying good
things about yours
um
parmesan cheese listener
so
what
parmesan cheese listen so this makes
complete Sense Once the context is
established
mostly a job in Northern Italy
ah this person Taps wheels of Parmesan
cheese with a hammer to ensure it is
ripe enough for sale
uh because you know it can take up to
three years it's kind of like thumping a
melon
but over the course of three years
this is just a delightful thing to think
about I mean first of all just knowing
that the tone of yes it's good to go how
often do you pretty cool just
find cheese in the fridge and just eat
it straight never
I without exaggeration I will say never
but if we are having a party and there's
cheese on stuff but you know so but
there's never a moment and you're still
like I gotta just eat this cheese I've
come to a conclusion about this because
I've thought about it I'm like
I've watched Christy eat cheese
and I've just observed that something
happens
that I am completely missing I don't
there's she's having an experience
what's your favorite food what's your
favorite flavor to put in your mouth
like when you put in your is it like an
ice cream or something like you put some
ice cream in your mouth and it like
gives you like I think close to like it
gets sexual I mean that's how I think
it's it whatever that way with chocolate
uh you know
yeah I mean more so than ice cream what
food makes you horny for food not horny
for sex I'm horny for more of that same
food I
I don't know it's like the first thing
that comes to mind and I the closest I
can get I think is
potato chips
really like they're very you know it's
very addictive see okay I want to keep
going with that that's an interesting
observation because I completely
understand definitely not sweet The
Addictive nature of a potato chip but
that is a completely different part of
my brain so in other words if I eat a
potato chip I'm like dang that's good I
gotta get another one and that is this
process that can lead to me eating an
entire bag of potato chips thankfully I
have the discipline usually to not do
that but cheese is completely different
that's what I've observed there's
something else lighting up in her brain
cheese and chocolate is completely
different so that is the exact flavor
that is happening it isn't like oh I've
got to eat a whole bag of cheese it's no
this cheese the way that this what is
happening in my mouth the complexity
of the flavor
the sharpness of it whatever it is that
is something that I don't think there's
any food that does it like that for me I
don't have that I just don't have it man
I feel sorry for you I know I'm I'm sad
for myself right now but just this
weekend I was uh Jesse was out of town
and I ended up not getting any takeout I
cooked every meal because I was just
like in this I don't know I was like I'm
just cooking I'm and not anything real
special I made like a pot of beans and I
made this like pasta where I like got
some you know just what the vegetables
that were in the fridge that needed it
were about to go bad and just kind of
made this pasta but
you know I knew you were home alone on
the weekend and I liked I dropped a
couple of hints like you know I can come
over we can hang out and I definitely
got the impression that you had your own
plans and now I understand
when you was like oh this is going to be
a me weekend well me and my beans I will
which I totally respect I will when I
get to my wreck I'll talk a little bit
more about this uh something I've kind
of like discovered and something I'm
moving into in the in the culinary world
but
I was reading
um so you got Noah who uh was on Josh's
was on hot dog is a sandwich recently
and uh has you know he has his new
cookbook okay yeah and he sent it to us
and
I was like I've never actually like read
a cookbook
I've never just sat down and be like Oh
I'm gonna like look at this and I'm
going to actually like look at a recipe
and follow the directions well it's not
a novel
you tell me you've never made something
from a cookbook well most modern
cookbooks are written more there's like
a there's more of a narrative and a more
of like a philosophical sort of
beginning when it gets into something
it's like oh we used to do this here's a
little story about my family you know uh
it's not just it's not your grandma's
cookbook huh you know what I mean okay
I'm into that and
he had he starts with these like Staples
like uh you know you this is how you do
this this is how you do this I always
and he's like I always have a pot of
beans like make a pot of beans at the
beginning of the week or whatever and I
was like this is a great idea what's the
name of the cookbook you should say it
is called the no Panic pantry is that
yeah that sounds right no Panic Pantry
cookbook
and uh you know his wife is Eliza who
was on Schlesinger yes who is on GMM
that's how we initially got to know
everybody
um
so anyway
he was giving his beans recipe and I
perched up a little bit yeah he did
because I don't really know what the
hell I'm doing when it comes to being
let us know that they taste good and
also it's kind of hard for them not to
taste good
but
he gave us when he gave us the cookbook
he gave us beans I don't know if you
noticed that he gave us beans and and
some Evo so I was like I'm gonna cook
these beans man
and oh I'm gonna and I'm gonna cook the
pasta he gave us some semolina pasta and
you followed his guidance yeah so I made
a pot of beans and one of the things
that he suggested to put in your beans
is a Parmesan rind
yeah so and I don't eat that part
it's very difficult to eat
okay I'm talking about the part that I'm
not talking about I'm talking about the
ends you know like
um because you can eat like
you can eat the rind of a lot of cheeses
but I guess you could eat the parmesan
rhyme there's lots of things you could
do if you go on Tick Tock you'll see
people doing all kinds of things with
Parmesan rice like putting them in the
microwave and making them in a little
like cheese puffs that are crispy
there's all kinds of things you can do
but I put it in the beans I made some
beans they were great I've still got
them I mean I have a huge pot of beans
that I'm slowly like
putting in things putting up putting
them in rice and anyway while I was
making my beans
I found some cheese because Jesse loves
cheese as well and we have like multiple
cheeses that are just kind of in the
cheese drawer and I found that Merlot
uh
it's like that Merlot like soaked cheese
yeah as Jasper doesn't like Merlot
that's what has been well established
he's growling what are you growling he
doesn't like Merlot we've been over this
it was a red wine flavored cheese
and it was you know it's just like a p
it's like the size of a piece of pie
and I just set it out and of course I'm
Just Me Myself and Shepherd's there he's
gonna eat whatever I make
but I'm like playing some music it's
just me Shepherd's there but it's just
me he's in the house he's not cooking
with me I'm playing some music
uh I actually listened to the whole uh
Freddie Gibbs album since you've been
talking about it which it was great it
was also a very interesting experience
to be like cooking this meal and eating
this cheese
it actually really worked well he has
another album called Alfredo that would
have been a better one I didn't know
yeah you should so I'm eating this piece
of cheese
like as a piece of pie
and I literally ate the whole thing by
myself
and it's triggering a part of your brain
and and I've got and I'm going back to
it I got this knife and I like cut a
little piece of it and I put it in like
like it's a spine tingling thing it's
like like yes it's like it's like an
orgasm I mean let's just be honest with
it I mean that's it's doing the same
thing that an orgasm does and then you
have a little cheese orgasm a cheesecasm
and then you keep cooking and you go
back I gotta get one a little bit more
that's not a potato chip my friend no
that does not happen with a potato chip
potato chip is it for me is like a blind
grabbing of more food which is really
good it's a munchie thing I think that's
what it is I'm a texture I'm a texture I
believe that you can find a food that
gives you a a a a taste gasm and it's
just really you should be on a quest to
find it how much do you do they do they
make tap and Parmesan forty thousand
dollars a year
uh which I mean I don't know in Northern
Italy that might might go a long way I
have no idea I haven't been okay
well give me another one
um we've only talked about one job
yeah but we it was it was a Parmesan
cheese listener so we had to take a
second to really go through it what
gives you a taste gasm
this completely makes sense Music and
Sound composer for slot machines oh yeah
yeah
I mean that's more pressier luck but I'm
not much of a gambler but
well a lot of them are licensed now like
they probably license some sort of theme
song to go along with uh the Miami Vice
slot machine yeah but
even if there is a
you know copyrighted song
that's like a theme song
you don't want that theme song to be
playing while you're playing because
slot machines are specific we know this
because we met someone who designs them
hypnotic uh this was one of the first
things I mean really early in our career
probably
2007 it's eight
when we went to good experience live in
yeah the gel conference New York City
and she was
either a journalist or psychologist or a
little bit of both and like she had
studied yeah she didn't do it she was
the um the addictive nature of the
gambling industry and how you know how
it's so there's so much science involved
in keeping you in that seat yeah and
getting in this like putting you in this
state of flow
where it's you know you can't you can't
get off the stool you just got to stay
there and like hit it again and hit it
again including like you and your cheese
not winning too much and not losing too
much both winning too much and losing
too much
takes people out of a flow that will
actually if they stay in the seat for
longer it will extract more of their
money which is what the casinos want
sure so they get psychologists to design
these machines and you know the music's
a part of that
yeah and so so Dave how much do they get
paid it's not all about how much you get
paid but they get between 68 and 81 000
a year so they're making a little bit
more I mean and they're contributing to
an industry that is just
sucking money out of people's walls
seems like they get paid more yeah
they need they need a better agent
um yeah so I mean they're basically
sitting there thinking about this is
what's going to happen when this happens
when you win this is what happens when
you lose this is what happens when
you're in the flow this is this is the
thing that we're going to play this is
the sound that
pulling this thing is going to make you
know what
I just decided I'm gonna try slots
because I just don't I there's no way I
would get sucked into it like I'm not
gonna play any other gambling but I am
going to
Vegas you know we
we solidified our our plans our football
Dad plans to go to Vegas it's quite a
group you got going here six of us be
careful six of us be careful what we're
gonna see a show
I I didn't plan on gambling I'll look
over people's children right there's
been a lot of movies about a group of
dads going to Vegas I haven't seen any
of these going The Hangover I haven't
seen it how many hangovers are there
at least two I guess I should watch them
there's three of them
well I better start now
cautionary tale huh I mean there's more
there's not there's also ones that are
not comedies it wasn't
Leaving Las Vegas entering Las Vegas
Fear and Loathing in Las Vegas
flying over Las Vegas
on your way to the Grand Canyon I'm much
more of a grand candy guy than a Vegas
guy but I'm going along for the ride
anybody in the group slots is easy
excited about gambling excited about
like blackjack poker I'm sure
yeah I mean I like to play poker have
you ever done slots but
just for like oh yeah let's just
put ten dollars into this thing or
whatever yeah
I think you were probably there it was
probably like on tour I didn't even go
down there like because there's smoking
down there and I don't like that there's
not smoking down there now is there some
of them
you have to go through smoking sections
you're still smoking a casino sections
and you know he knows you can smoke just
as long as you're by the games
see I can't stand that okay I also can't
stand gambling it's just you know it's
it's I think it's it's like cheese it's
like no it's not
no it's not man it doesn't come on dude
and it's not that I don't have an
addictive personality or addictive
whatever the thing is I do think I have
some of that like when I really like
something I'm like I'm all in
and I don't know if I would call that
addictive okay
because addictive personalities tend to
jump
two different things and get drawn into
things I think you have a you're
committed to things like you like once
you find something you like you like you
follow through with it but I don't know
so that I don't hurt its feelings but
you're not a dick I will probably stay
at that slot machine so that I don't
offend it
um
I really want to go but I don't I don't
want to leave it alone it's going to
think I don't like it I don't I've never
had a rewarding experience and I mean
and I'm I've won some money gambling or
like playing poker but
I can't say that I've ever looked back
at the time that I spent
doing any of that and thought to myself
I had a great time even in times when
I've been gambling or like most of the
time it would be playing poker like I I
barely know the rules of blackjack
but
the idea that you would play poker with
like a group of friends right like this
is a concept that exists yeah
but what I found in the in the circles
that I have done this in
no one's really up for conversation
They're all playing a game you know what
I'm saying like
um
there's been a couple of environments
that I was in where I was like okay I
kind of feel like the main thing I'm
here to do is like hang out with these
people and and okay now me and this guy
are talking but now
these guys are upset with us because
every time it comes around to us we
don't immediately react because we're
not here to play poker we're here to
connect and so I think you have to make
a choice and then if it's just like just
a bunch of people sitting around
competing against each other now
obviously there's a part of me that that
appeals to but I'm also like this is
going to take
we're gonna be here for hours and I'm
most likely going to lose money because
my brain gets real tired and those
like multiple steps of strategy and like
we have to figure out what he what this
guy's got and what you've got and your
odds and all that stuff my brain just
kind of decides that it's not it's it's
it's done pretty early don't even get me
started meaning I couldn't even start
um and so I don't know I've never found
it rewarding
so if I was going to Vegas with you
thanks for inviting me I was I you know
I didn't want to be invited I mean as a
television media founder I have a very
busy schedule I I think you need to be
alone I have multiple you know I have
like a lot of people protecting my time
and uh I probably couldn't do it anyway
and I don't know any of these guys and
it would be weird it would actually be
you do not know any of that episode I'm
bringing my best friend
I bring him everywhere
no I don't want to go
you the thing that I find very
interesting is not if you have you have
stated on multiple occasions how much
you dislike Las Vegas yes and you're
going I like their company and I want to
see uh a Cirque du Soleil show that
should be fun we're going to see oh
there's water oh there's water there's
water involved
no boobies though no boobies it's not
zootopia
nope
whatever there was have we done this
joke in real life are we still talking
about oh
I think we've done it on this show have
we done the zootopia zoom in anything on
this show or was that just in a group of
friends
that was a fun little joke when it
happened wherever it happened yeah that
was a throwback just for me thank you
um zumanity
okay zootopia are not the same thing
okay I did not question whether or not I
would be into this next job uh an
e-nucleator otherwise known as an ibank
technician
this person extracts the entire eyeball
or the corneas of the eye this is done
on those who have passed you know oh yes
yes dead folks who are organ donors
um okay and then basically taking them
to the lab getting them ready to
transplant into someone who needs them
which just to be transformative for
people
people who have certain forms of
blindness or eye cancer
it's basically a way to keep the eye
socket intact and kind of like put a new
cornea on there you know otherwise you
gotta like get their eye out of their
socket
for sure I don't want to tap your eye
socket Until It Breaks
so the these people are really good at
plucking eyeballs out of dead people
yeah they make that sound when it
happens
I mean it seems like it just all comes
down to just a tool right it's probably
one specialized tool it's not like
you know like a hammer and chisel I'm
sure if you're taking the eyeball out
there's some sort of vacuum it's
probably just a Dyson with a certain
fixture on it
you know you gotta watch out don't get a
vacuum close to your face
oh my gosh uh this can we let's move on
well you only I don't even make 38 to 40
000 a year doing it too you know I feel
like you should get more money than that
if you are
sucking people's eyeballs out
get the sucking out it's easier than the
putting in
I don't know is it is it the same tool
is it a different tool well this is it
as much as I would hate to see it I kind
of want to see it well I don't have any
pictures
good but you know that the person who's
putting the eye
cornea or whatever into a living person
is making
a [__] ton of money oh yeah right that's
like a surgeon yeah they're working with
a living person who can sue you
yeah uh
uh so yeah so you want to be working
with the what I'm learning here is you
want to be working with the living and
not the Dead
yeah
it's a lot of trouble it just depends on
what your dreams are I guess a lot more
opinions
this feels like something that you in
another life could be good at this next
one uh it feels even though ironically
you're not great with numbers it just
feels like there's something about this
that would appeal to your personality
and that is to work for the Department
of weights and measures as an inspector
okay is it an authority figure this is
basically a trained inspector that goes
around and tests whether or not
consumers are actually getting the
amount of product they pay for oh
a measurement police so like it's like
it's like
Barney Fife but with a ruler
yeah I mean you're going in that's me
baby like a grocery store making sure
that like they say that this is uh you
know a pound and a half a steak well
let's make sure it is oh and by the way
while I'm here let me test your scale
all these scales that you've got all
over the grocery store
um
and some people might say government
jobs it is a government position and
this is where you get into uh let's get
political how about that because
um you know like like many people
you know I once at one point in my life
like read a book by a Libertarian and
thought that sounded great you know
I was like oh yeah the government
shouldn't do anything
should weigh it should be meaningless
weights and measure the market will take
care of itself yeah if you're if you're
if you're charging if you're if you're
trying to pass off a pound of meat is a
pound and a half a meat
you'll get found out
probably not actually you probably just
deceive a lot of people
uh but anyway
yes this is a government position to
make sure that the things that people
are selling
are what they say they are specifically
in the measurement of those things what
what are there any other examples
uh grabbing produce or deli meat grocery
stores uh going around to different gas
stations and testing that each pump is
actually spitting out a gallon when the
meter says it is oh
um
so they've got like this special
tank that's exactly a gallon
that's just a gas tank yeah
this is special tank I mean what I would
like to see this this person's vehicle
you know there's this little thing
there's probably lots of containers I
thought you'd get excited about this and
like
measures and stuff but could you I bet
he's got like laser measurements
and Laser scales I feel like this is
something that you could get excited
about like if you think about what your
day would involve right but then you're
but then you're seeing it you're the
enemy yeah you're the overlord enemy but
are you really yeah it's like because
it's not like a health inspector telling
me my ham scale is off
now I gotta get a new scale how much is
this gonna cost yeah if you're going
around to like New York delis maybe but
I would think that the average business
actually wants their stuff to be
accurate well that's what the person
says I think that you want this
information yeah yeah yeah I think you
want yeah you're doing a service
but okay aside from the interaction with
people loading up a car full of
one gallon tanks just traveling around
the county and you got a ruler imagine
you've got a belt with things on it I
know you're like measure man you know
I feel like you'd be into this
because it's making sure that something
is Right making sure that something is
what is is what it is purported to be I
think I would be comfortable
taking bribes in this profession because
what's the worst that can happen oh you
got a little less ham I like Pat my
pockets you know I put some ham in my
britches you know what I'm saying you
know what I'm saying I wonder how I mean
that I wonder how common it is for
somebody to be a crooked measurement of
weights and measures inspector just the
corruption is just rampant in the in the
in the weights and measures division
I mean I would think that the guy's
driving from from town to town from gas
station to gas station and like a you
know rolls man I would think that there
are places where
um bribery and Corruption is to sort of
part of the way that government is done
which is many many places and it's also
the United States but for whatever
reason
the US is kind of known for when it
comes to these kinds of things of like
they're not being a lot of corruption at
that level it's like okay yeah it's
probably gonna be a gallon
um I don't know exactly why that is but
it tends to be the case
so you probably get into a [__] ton of
trouble
if you did it in the United States but
this might be it this might be something
that's happening in other places it
might it sounds like a good plot for a
TV show
yeah as a as a television media founder
I have to think about these things
if somebody if something seems like it
would make a great series idea that's a
winner that's what I usually say you
know this could be a winner it could be
a winner
I guess I'm just gonna Vlog about it
um there are a series of
people who do things that you would not
think needed to be
Professionals for okay
starting with professional mourners
I I think I've heard about this one well
you know about this they show up at
funerals you know about this Jenna oh
yeah I would absolutely do this yeah you
know you have to you have to like
you have to be sad for people that you
don't know so that the people who do
know that person feel like that that
person knew somebody I cry at
commercials oh I can do that no problem
I mean have you been tempted to crash a
funeral
well
it was like well I'll just stand in the
in the back and I remember this story
respectful right I don't know if I ever
do that story well I'll remember it
let's hear it measurement remember
there's something familiar about it I I
agree but well okay tell us a story I
you ever just walk around somewhere and
you you're a funeral town
you realize it's a funeral and you're
like oh oh I I kind of wear those people
that I'm like oh I once wonder what's
going on in there and I'll just pop my
head in and then like a church or a
funeral home or a cemetery
it was a cemetery yeah yeah yeah so I
knew what was going but I was curious
and right yeah blending right in just
weeping like a baby yeah
I've been to enough funerals yeah uh
apparently it's pretty popular in China
uh the idea being to make a funeral feel
more full and also to help people grieve
by sort of like beginning to cry right
it's like the first person to start
applauding they also May uh even perform
karaoke and dance routines what yeah
uh-huh
but again this uh that's just to warm up
the crown that's that's something that
happens at Chinese funerals I guess
um so it's a fake I they're fake wailing
they're probably able to tap into
something and be very convincing but
it's conjured
but who knows
that they're a professional mourner
because if like
well I think that they did it's just a
part of it's a part of it but like if
you died
and we were having your funeral and
there was somebody there
who I did not know
who was really getting into who is this
[__] but if you were in China
you would know
it's just part of it oh you're saying
it's a helpful service you're saying
that oh yeah that's the professional
more that's the PM
right yeah he's pretty good pretty good
oh yeah pretty convincing I'm gonna get
your card
the best ones rise to the top they
charge a little bit more as easily as I
cry at commercials no whimpering I don't
think I would be good at this
because it's too real into visceral I
tend to cry at things that I feel
separated from which I guess
not knowing a person who died yeah you
and Janna
but you know what would get me at
funerals
a a loved one telling a good story about
them I I could I could cry boy I'll cry
in that situation I don't have to know
anything about this person
maybe I could do this but I'm I'm so big
you know I'm it's a scene who's a tall
guy dressing all black they think you do
a grim reaper
these guys gonna get me next yeah don't
wear a hood Homie
don't bring your Sith
uh the salary is based on the the events
so you can make up to 500 per event it's
not a bad day karaoke
uh I've heard of this one before as well
uh uh professional bridesmaid
this is someone hired to be in a wedding
party
that's that feels a little more awkward
but maybe is this a
another culture no uh uh the article
that this comes from was talking about
someone who's doing this in America and
it kind of sounds like a
glorified wedding planner for things
that are a little bit more tertiary
it's like you need your bridesmaid to
like tell you what
she thinks about your dress Etc and oh
that kind of thing
uh that seemed to be the way that it was
contextualized in this particular
article it's like something's like maybe
you don't have a friend that you trust
you know and so you get somebody who's
like uh why don't you just kind of be
here to like hold down the fort and just
you know you've got some sense and my
friends don't
kind of thing but the sad situation
would be more of a consultant you just
don't have
enough friends to to fill out a wedding
party
which I've been to weddings like that
well you want you want the number of
groomsmen to match the number of
Bridesmaids and sometimes that doesn't
happen I've been to a wedding where
there was
one
dreams man and like six Bridesmaids
because they were like we don't We're
Not Gonna not like that's okay yeah I
felt bad you feel bad for the groom
yeah he needed for some professional
I could have loaned out a few I had way
too many
I had 19 groomsmen and seven ushers and
we both did the same thing all my
friends with a bunch of groomsmen and
then ushers
with the friends that couldn't fit on
stage we had a big time
um yeah we definitely didn't need any
Professionals in that situation I I'm
not like this is not appealing to me
at all I don't I don't really I don't
really like the whole wedding all the
aspects the pageantry and all that I
mean I'd rather go to a wedding in a
funeral don't get me wrong this is the
planning aspect when it comes to parties
in general
like I'll like I said I'll cook for you
and I will put my heart and soul into
that and I will really think about that
aspect of it I also like organizing like
a game for a group of people
but
I don't know when it moves into like
you've got to walk this way at this time
according to at this where this song is
playing and this is like the order of
things that happen again so you're not
going to renew your vows Christy told me
this morning she had a dream that you
and Jesse renewed your vows
like a big wedding
Jesse had a conversation about this
recently
um you're considering it no I I think I
think I was like
I think I said I just don't think I
would ever do that I don't think I would
ever have a vowel renewal
it's in Wheel of Fortune man it's a
vowel not a vowel
vowel renewal vowel
a vowel and I said I add L's to words
that don't have them and leave them out
of words that do have them that's one of
my things well I pronounce the H's in
words because they're in them
the white I told her that I thought that
a vow renewal was a sign that things
were not going well yeah I totally
believe that and she was like no it's
just like you want to have a party and
have friends and stuff but to me it's
like
I feel like when somebody has a new
renewal it's like uh he cheated you know
what I'm saying like that that I'm not
saying that I'm not saying that's what
it always happens we're trying that's
what I'm trying to turn a big oh they've
been going to counseling and they
decided to stick it out
yep and I'm just like and that's just a
party that's it
maybe it's appropriate for that maybe I
don't understand I I don't I know I
don't I think those are good reasons to
have a vowel renewal when it's like so
I'm not dogging those reasons it's just
that's why I'm not in a position where I
want to renew my vowels you know because
because I'm not like I'm not I'm not
coming back from the bottom of the
barrel you know I'm not trying to turn a
big Corner we have talked about how it's
kind of like having a like having a like
it is the difference between having an
anniversary party you know it's like oh
uh 40th wedding anniversary exact
wedding anniversary if you turn it into
a vowel renewal well that something else
is going on that's what I think a party
that is about a couple
would be fun
I I that would be fun yeah but when it
gets a ceremony specific
renewal part
I don't know I guess people could be
like Hey listen renewal music got old I
want to let you know exactly like you
don't really do it like a warranty on
something unless it runs out right you
know
you don't like I'm getting my I'm
getting my so and so refinished
why come on because it was dull
yeah it was dull and Bland was over it I
was thinking about throwing it away and
then we decided to refinish it yeah
yeah we've just we have just crapped all
over anyone who was planning a renew
like the difference between having a
birthday party hey come to my 40th
rebirth ceremony
that would be weird you show up at
somebody's 40th birthday party and they
like
crawl out of a womb
no you know like it's paper mache
it's not slimy no it's really dry well
you don't want a wet paper mache
well it's it's just for the moment
yeah but then it's like ripping you know
all that that's it comes out with some
like no I think that maybe yeah like you
don't want that too
uh you know what I'm saying let's just
go to Vegas you know what I'm saying
I think there's good reasons for vow
renewals I just wanted
okay I'm gonna throw out two reasons
that are good reasons for bow renewals
one they didn't get the wedding that
they wanted for whatever reason okay
good good answer okay good answer good
answer two I read a really great book a
few years back called love lives here
and it's a story of a married couple and
um one of the partners transitioned to a
woman so they renewed their vows okay
that makes sense with
her as her true self that's a big Corner
yes so yeah yeah something there was a
change yes okay yeah okay those
scenarios make sense okay so the
budgeting one that also makes sense I
mean the reason that Jesse and I have
had even a conversation about this is
because our I was just talking to
somebody about this the other day
our wedding was not indicative at all of
who we have become right it was like
obviously it was super duper Christian
right it was it was it was a totally
Christian ceremony it was all about hey
let's read these scriptures listening
these songs and my the vowels were very
much about some things that I actually
didn't keep my vow I didn't keep my vow
I said I was gonna always follow Jesus
and Lead You In this relationship and
that I did I'm not doing that anymore
still happily married more happily
married than ever sounds like you might
need a renewal man we didn't have
alcohol at our wedding you know she
would have a wedding just going out she
wasn't even old enough to drink
she's 20.
um
so yeah we would do things a lot
differently Jenny you changed his mind
but yeah yeah
destination vow renewal I will be there
and I think destination that's what I'm
saying oh of course of course
but I still just think you make it an
anniversary party is all I'm saying
is it if if there's not uh
um a corner turned
then I and it's just really hey we just
love each other want to celebrate our
love in the context of our family and
friends in the way that we would
celebrate our love now
I don't know anniversary but maybe there
is like a little maybe there's a little
ceremony of sorts I haven't found any
job that I want to do what about
professional cure and this is someone
who stands in line
for people who don't want to stand in
line
like I want the new PlayStation but I
don't want to go camp out for it
whatever is required you can pay
somebody approximately 20 to 25 an hour
very popular in the UK
I wonder why and then
um I think it's because it's called a
cure like we we don't in America we
don't know we don't have a good line
line standards like what what does that
mean a liner
that's something a bit of a truck you
know we just don't have a name for it
that's the reason why no one does it
here this is for a basically a rich
person who doesn't want to waste their
time
I mean this that's what we're looking at
here
you know with the right equipment I
could be good at standing in a line
what would be the equipment like one of
those chairs that's attached to your
butt yeah yeah you just you sit down and
it comes out and then you stand back up
yeah you don't ever have to touch it it
look it looks like you're wearing a
really long butt plug yeah it's just a
stool yeah
it's a stool that sticks out like a tail
right it's a it's a cane
for your it's asking it's going up your
butt yeah yeah it's an ass cane
um I wouldn't do that I don't I mean I
can't think of anything I want anyone to
wait in line for like I've never ever
except one waited in a line no no no no
like those things where you got to get
up at 3am the only thing I've ever done
that was back in the day I did I did a
Black Friday TV Best Buy no I I I was in
a tent uh waiting for tickets basketball
tickets back when they used to do that
NC State that was fun that was fun and I
remember
this freshman year it was for the
Carolina game
and we were in the tent and it was like
one guy in the tent at a time yep
someone had always be there you had this
you had you had your system and your
rotation people go to class and they
would take over it was like for a couple
of days I remember waking up in the
middle of the night because it was very
difficult to sleep because it was
allowed because it was a bunch of
college students camping out
and I like hear some commotion and unzip
the tent and I look and there's just
like a couch
on fire
yep and and unfortunately uh that was
the last time they let anyone camp out
for tickets at State because things got
that so much hell was raised yeah I
didn't actually do the camping out
but you got to go to the game I think I
did
someone had to be smart and keep the
grades up he's like I'll take one for
the team I'll be working on my grades
really I need my sleep I can't
um
so anyway yeah you did a TV a Black
Friday line I think so
it went when and what TV I think when we
first moved out here because I remember
there was a Best Buy near your house
maybe in California it wasn't a TV maybe
it was it was some sort of Christmas
present
I can't remember what it was
okay couple more doesn't matter
this is one I could not have told you
existed a face feeler otherwise known as
a sensory scientists so what
I mean thinking 25 bucks an hour so
you're not
really raking it in but
uh
what you do
is there are all these products that
people use like a razor or anti-aging
serum
some face lotion
and you can't just give somebody a razor
and have them shave and have them feel
their skin to tell you how smooth it is
because they don't know
you have to get a set of hands on a
person who is feeling faces this is like
the measurement up to 25 faces a day
to make sure that these products are
living up to their standards
so that there's like a it's a control
it's control hands if somebody would
that is like no actually you think that
razor is good it's not good I feel faces
all freaking day you know what I'm
saying
I I just think that I would like to be
on the receiving end of that
you know I've had a good face massage
before
uh okay I can see that you would like
I've never just sat down for nothing but
a face massage but there's been a couple
of times where I've got like a full body
thing and there's been a face portion to
it and I'm like you know what this is
pretty good I feel like
I feel like something's happening to my
sinuses like really like really deep in
the chest oh and you know with me and my
chewing and my
my talking and my my mouth flapping it's
like yeah getting all this stuff
oh yeah
oh yeah just make it melt yeah I'm not
into that I'm not into watching you do
it and I'm not into thinking about it
being done
but you do not end up feeling people's
faces nope
I'm a receiver
um
how about a paper towel sniffer this is
your last one uh you're ending with this
one nope I'm not gonna end with that one
paper towel sniffer
what what this is somebody who works for
the company to certify that they're
putting the right scent on it or
something it's just basically if you
make paper towels you don't want them to
smell like anything
like there's something and it takes a
person have you ever thought about that
like a good roll of paper towels you
just smell it and you're like
they don't have a smell
yeah I I guess I never thought about
that and I think that's a toilet paper
sometimes has a scent if it's scented
right yeah and uh trash bags do
definitely but you don't want a paper to
have like an off-gassing smell like
right if you if you smell like paper
paper
this is actually pretty good paper
because it doesn't smell like
it doesn't smell like anything it just
smells like maybe like a tree you know
yeah that's I think I'm smelling the ink
but I feel like if you get cheap paper
it smells like chemicals
get cheap toilet paper or paper towels
so that's somebody's job and they're
making 52 Grand a year uh
but
you saved the best for last a panda
fluffer
I'll make a panda floofy
it's like
so like combing a panda no no no
you know what a fluffer is
I've heard the term but
[Music]
I think I I think the first time I ever
heard about a fluffer it was somebody
who makes sure that uh a male
um
porn performer is ready to go
oh and making sure that he stays ready
to go no pillows involved
um but apparently a panda fluffer as you
know they're an endangered species and
they need to have sex with one another
and apparently to make more pandas yeah
uh they are not great at it I mean you
can kind of look at them and tell that
they're probably not good at sex you
ever seen a panda do anything
uh like they're like a panda every day
bamboo every time you see a panda doing
anything it's like they're not doing it
well have you ever seen a video of a
potato but besides eating bamboo so
pandas walking great no it's like that
painted looks like maybe something's
wrong
like that painted I feel like it's about
to fall over like every I mean I don't
know all the panda videos actually just
go
I think maybe we should just let them go
I mean you know just let them do we need
them what do you need them for I mean
yeah you if
you gonna have to renew your vows on
some Panda man yeah yeah cause we hang
around I love pandas you can't do
anything well except be cute but you
know what I think pandas being cute is
good enough good enough reason to keep
them around uh
important part of an ecosystem
intervention
yeah you gotta get a panda hard
come on now don't just
you gotta fluff it fluff is a good word
I that's like the perfect word for it uh
like I feel like I'm making my bed well
they don't say hard they don't say that
Well it can't be soft it doesn't work
they use a feather duster
uh and other instruments bring in the
eye plucker to see what he can do to
cautiously help turn pandas on bring in
the measurement too while you're at it
you know somebody's got to certify
um I mean think about it like you're
just trying to get pandas
feather dust you get to get it on
and feather duster provides twenty seven
thousand dollars a year for this I mean
I well you're you're being paid in other
ways yeah right there's there's really
there's a satisfaction in the job itself
I will say I don't a few people get to
work that closely with pandas I don't
think a panda could actually
hurt you okay I bet you a panda could
kill you I know no listen here this is
again I know it's a bear I know it's
probably strong but I think a panda
would like take a swipe at you miss you
and fall over and like do a Somerset
like that's how and then everyone would
applaud that's not a picture of panda
trying to attack you like that there's
no way he's actually gonna make contact
I mean they've got us fooled man they've
really got us wrapped around their
finger I mean to be honest with you it's
not a surprise that they have it that
we're having to help them out
you know right it is spoiled Grizzlies
on the other hand they're just thriving
you know I don't know I actually do
certain places I think we basically
killed every brown bear in California
fluff a Grizzly they're still on the
flag but they are completely extinct
uh because that's what people do
uh I'm just making light of it because
sometimes you just have to you have to
Laugh to Keep from Crying fluffing ain't
easy uh so I'm I I'm glad you ended but
I fully believe in this uh I believe in
the fluffing of pandas and I am a pro
Panda and I will say
vote for me if you do like I said
earlier if you do any of these jobs
especially if you're a panda fluffer if
you're a panda fluffer
we may actually have you on the show
okay
uh I mean it depends on how charismatic
you are when we talk to you on the phone
uh we'll at least do a segment
of panda fluffing
hey okay let's see this is a normal
duster I mean what is like what kind of
duster all I got to say is now that
we're you know we're we're doing all
kinds of content
we've left a panda feels like a winning
internet video
I don't want that okay I don't want that
on me I got long arms and I'm quick I'm
Fleet footed and I got long arms
I think I can do it
are you a long feather duster
uh let me give you a recommendation good
luck in your job search yeah you're
welcome I mean listen employment uh
unemployment is really really low right
now there but there's it's it's really
there's still a lot of opportunities out
there and we've just given you that many
more options
um
I've gotten really into a Reddit thread
called cast iron what
it's just people talking about their
cast iron pans
and that's that's all over the internet
people restoring them I like that well
yeah but seasoning right which again I
didn't really when people talk about
seasoning a pan I was like
don't really know what you're talking
about seasoning is a real is kind of a
misnomer because it really just means
heating oil on the surface of the cast
iron to a certain temperature so that
basically becomes a non-stick pan and a
lot of people like me for years I like
everybody has a cast iron pan that some
relative gave them right
and I would cook with it and it would
like man this isn't good like I don't
know how to clean it you're not supposed
to put soap on it or whatever like your
things stick to it like I'm obviously
this is [__] technology we should
use non-stick right and then you realize
the Zen of cast iron and also stainless
steel pans like you go into like a fine
restaurant they're not going to have
Teflon or they're not going to have
non-stick pans because those things work
for a couple of months and in a
restaurant setting it'll probably work
for a couple of weeks and then they the
coating comes off whatever and so these
people in restaurants actually just know
how to cook properly on these surfaces
but what's on the thread well the thing
that's really been blowing up on the
thread recently is a guy who did 80
coats of seasoning on his pan and made
it into that
what is that what am I looking at the
bottom of a pan that's like gray no no
it's
like a mirror
very clear it's
no you don't understand you don't really
you don't really look at cast iron pans
before right you're like okay they're
black yeah but they're not shiny so a
cast iron pan that you just buy is going
to be a matte surface yeah this guy did
the seasoning
process 80 times in a row as he says I'm
at 80 coats now don't do it guys this is
just for Internet cloud and for Science
and also to make random internet
strangers unreasonably mad
and so everybody all everybody on the
thread is pretty excited about this
right now because it's so shiny it's
just so glossy I gotta say mine's kind
of glossy but I've got I did like a
three or four three or four you know
coats this is a strong recommendation
today and it wants you to look at
seasoned cast iron pans on Reddit well
and this is kind of beyond the the
Reddit thread and it I am recommending
that you ditch your non-stick pans and
you get cast iron pans and stainless
steel pans and learn how to actually use
them properly and you'll and you'll
thank me you will thank me
all right
let us know what you actually think
about all this hashtag your biscuits
leave us a voicemail one eight eight
hey Rhett and Link My name is Heather
and I've got a really unique business
which is why I think it's so crazy that
you guys basically explained what it is
on Link's uh deconstruction episode on
your most recent episode of the podcast
um so basically I've made an entire
business out of taking people to the zoo
adult people at that and we go around
each week focusing on a different animal
and the different things that we can
learn from the animal so I just think
it's awesome link that you've kind of
discovered that intuitively on your own
and I know from experience and reviews
that can be a positive powerful thing so
keep it up that's awesome bye
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
foreign